hi there Steve here again 90 day
challenge I'm trying to work on my
Korean everyday I'm trying to do a video
every day on my how I'm coping
and again if you enjoy this channel
please subscribe today I want to talk
again about this intermediate vs. fluent
and what we mean and so forth and so on
today first of all I've easily my Korean
I haven't done a thing I played hockey
this morning came home to make lunch and
clean up and now I have to go to the
office tonight the Canucks are on
television that's the local hockey team
the Vancouver Canucks but I still want
to try to squeeze in I want to try and
save at least a hundred create a hundred
links a day if I look at my statistics
I'm kind of falling behind that the last
couple of days but I have been more or
less staying on that pace so that if I'm
doing that then I'm adding new
vocabulary and exposing myself to the
structure and all that is good so
somehow I've got to find the time to do
that today but I want to get back to
this discussion there's a lot of
interest in this and I want to read some
of the comments and also get back to
what exactly be to is in the European
framework in fact maybe we'll start with
that let's just look up here and okay b2
is described as first of all the
European framework talks but basic user
a independent user be and proficient
user see and my point was that b2 was
enough to call yourself fluent now let
me step back and say in my opinion to be
fluent you have to speak well when we
talk about fluency we're not talking
about fluency in reading we're talking
about fluency in speaking and in order
to speak well you have to speak a lot in
my experience those languages where I
consider myself fluent are the languages
that I have spoken the most sort of in
order after English is French and then
Japanese and then Mandarin and then
Spanish and then German and or maybe
Swedish ahead of German but those are
the language that I've spoken the most
Russian I don't think I'm far away from
being fluent but I haven't spoken very
much I've been
rusha a total of two weeks or 12 days or
so and have had some conversations by
Skype but I have enough vocabulary and I
understand it very well that if I were
given a week in Russia I'm sure I feel
confident that I could get to be fluent
is how the other languages like check
for example today going to hockey I
didn't listen to Korean I listened to
check because I'm subscribed to these
podcasts Yocto vidi came up there was
Yosef boxer who is with the Supreme
Court there and he was head he's very
interesting guy and he was talking about
the role of elites and how we live in a
wonderful time and you know refugees in
Europe and it was a very interesting
discussion so I listened to my check I
feel if I had a couple of weeks in the
Czech Republic I could maybe get myself
to fluent in Czech
but I'm not in those languages fluency
with Portuguese I would need more
exposure more opportunity to speak
Italian polish Ukrainian you know and
that Korean is even further away from
being fluent so getting back to fluency
and b2 now tip become fluent in a
language you have to speak a lot in
order to speak a lot to me I have to
have meaningful conversations I can't
talk about the weather all the time in
order to have meaningful conversations
in my opinion you have to understand
what the other person is saying and
therefore you need a fairly large
vocabulary so I think b2 is sort of a
precondition for being fluent and if you
have enough opportunity to practice the
language you will be flood even at a b2
level that means making mistakes so
description of b2 according to Wikipedia
herewith and I'm sure they've taken it
off the European framework website can
understand the main ideas of complex
texts complex texts on both concrete and
abstract topics including technical
discussions in their field of
specialization can interact with a
degree of fluency and spontaneity that
makes regular interaction with native
speakers quite possible without strain
for either party can produce clear
detailed text produce text here on a
wide range of subjects and explain a
viewpoint on a topical issue giving the
advantages of
of various options that's pretty good in
my view the distance the time it takes
to get from b1 to b2 is very long I
think I can move fairly quickly to be 1
and then from b1 to b2 is a long road
that's my view all right so that is in
so far as that is concerned now let's
look at some of the comments we had ok
no vinícius ra asks you know how can you
have meaningful conversations before you
had achieved an advanced level well this
is the point I think intermediate like
b2 is the level at which you can start
to have meaningful conversations and
that means that your speaking ability
can go up Parker Hayes looks for
perfection but is happy with less than
perfection this is what I was saying of
course I aspire to be as good as I can
in the language and I enjoy it my stay
with it but if I'm at b2 which some
people might consider intermediate I'm
happy and I consider myself fluent how
long does it take to reach a c2 level in
English by listening and reading well
you can't just do it listening reading
when you get to that b2 level yeah my
experience you've got to start speaking
a lot if you want to achieve C do C 2
but in order to move yourself to C 2 you
have to do a lot of listening and
reading because you have to have a wide
vocabulary before you can call yourself
C 2 like if I were to evaluate my own
languages I would say that I'm perhaps a
C 1 C 1 in French he might be getting
close but not totally a c2 but pretty
close in French Japanese I'm a B 2 C 1 a
Chinese have a B 2 and then I like a
strong B 2 and then in Spanish German
Swedish I'm just a normal B 2 and then
in some of those other languages where I
have a very large vocabulary I'm
potentially like in terms of my reading
and listening skills of a beat or even a
C 1 but I have to put a lot of time
speaking before I could be a fluent
speaker there for a b2 speaker in those
languages
and some people say you have to be it's
you know I disagree oh and here's
jupiter-like says only after completing
c1 well I'm going by the description I'm
not going by someone who took the test I
have never taken the test I don't know
what it's like I go by the description
that I gave you
Jupiter light says that I reach b2 in
German in two months and had zero
background German yeah maybe then you're
exceptionally good because I consider
that very very unlikely that most people
could achieve that in fact it takes a
long time to get to a competent b2 so
what do we got here you know and then
someone said well you know then I agree
with sort of Benny's definition of
fluency I've heard many different
definitions from Benison many one that
you know you can be fluent as long as
you can speak another one says that he
can do anything in the language that he
can do in his own language that in fact
is up in the seas so I don't think that
we can say fluency is just any old thing
but we can have somewhat different
positions on fluency I've outlined what
I consider to be my position it equates
to that b2 as per the description that I
read out other people can have other and
and in a way it doesn't really matter
because ultimately we learn our
languages for our own purposes so you've
got to decide what your goal is what
your purpose what your needs are and
then that's what you've got to strive
for
anyway running out of time here and I
got to run off to the office so thanks
for listening and bye for now